nueva polémica de las calles de Francia
a principios de abril el periódico le
parisian avanzó que la secretaria de
estado de economía social McLean iba a
aparecer en la portada de Playboy y la
revista ya llegó a los quioscos lo que
ha despertado sentimientos diferentes
entre la sociedad gala es provocador
para que la gente hable de ello ya ves
que estamos hablando de ello Así que es
un éxito
se habla de ello para no hablar de otras
cosas se habla de Marlene chapa en vez
de hablar de las pensiones estés de
acuerdo o no la portada es un poco
vulgar
en la portada con un vestido blanco y su
mano derecha en el corazón en una
alusión no buscada según su equipo de
comunicación a la célebre pintura de la
libertad guiando al pueblo desde la crua
la prensa local reportó que la primera
ministra Elizabeth reprendió a Chapa por
elegir este momento de tensión Social
para posar para la revista y la cuestión
también desencadenó las críticas de la
posición en un país donde el presidente
habla en la revista infantil pib y su
ministra en Playboy el problema Sería la
oposición Francia se está descarrilando
la secretaria de estado que sí recibió
el respaldo de algunos miembros del
ejecutivo salió a justificar su decisión
defender el derecho de las mujeres a
decir sobre su propio cuerpo es una
cuestión que se plantea en todas partes
y a todas horas en Francia las mujeres
son libres digan lo que digan los
retrógrados e hipócritas una
controversia aumentada y que muchos
consideran que saca del foco el problema
principal del gobierno la Reforma
pensional aprobada por decreto que ha
sacado a millones de franceses A las
calles durante 11 jornadas de huelga
general